jo-lynn home and the star shadow head to
the net dot to repair their gear in time
for the next opening but Quinn and the
crew of the American ladies night is
just beginning they're heading out to
pump an enormous set of herring off the
Crimson Beauty the Crimson beauty's
already filled three tenders and they're
still a massive fish in the net
[Music]
come on baby search live for us
other boats are pumping late into the
night as well and as hours go by there's
no sign of an end to the fish
[Music]
Quinn and his crew spent all night
humming the Crimson beauty
their set is bigger than anyone could
have imagined including captain Steven
sedan I thought I said not 150-ton set
after we filled up our 400 ton tender
and we still hadn't done anything with
just saying that you know something was
going I was a little bigger than I would
be it turns out to be Stevens biggest
set ever people 910 I love it you know I
never dreamed I'd ever see us hit like
that at 900 tons
the Crimson Beauty has the equivalent
weight of five jumbo jets in its net in
this one set alone
Steven and his crew have made upwards of
a half million dollars in town word of
yesterday's enormous couch spreads
quickly
you know is about 45 minutes into it you
know we're getting a couple estimates of
a hundred tons two hundred tons you know
nothing really that spectacular but as
the hard numbers continue to pour in
it's clear original estimates were well
on the conservative side well turned out
it sets down on the south end where
massive unprecedented size huge I mean
just absolutely huge it's looking like
some of those sets might be in the
thousand ton range something that's
never been seen in this fishery before
if you've got the big sets who ever did
really really well normally
traditionally they'll just come in the
bar and ring the bell and it costs them
a few hundred bucks every time they ring
I've actually seen some people that have
rang at several times you know spent a
couple thousand in just one hour of
fishing the Sitka fleet caught just
under ten thousand tons of herring
making over five and a half million
dollars
[Music]
you'll never catch this mini hearing in
one day ever again biggest sets ever in
history this one will be one in our
memory book we'll never see it happen
again I'm sure one boat netted one
thousand four hundred and sixty tons the
largest herring set in Alaska's history
as a million dollars sad